l'open de france sous les nuages et la
pluie
pas de quoi désespérer pour autant les
visiteurs toujours aussi nombreux dans
les allées autour des carrières dans les
boutiques
ils sont partout c'est une véritable
ville il ya effectivement cet hôtel mais
il ya aussi les pôles de restauration
les sanitaires et puis tout toute la
partie sportive avec les juges les
bénévoles les équipes qui préparent les
terrains c'est près de 400 personnes qui
collaborent au tour de la fédération 400
personnes et environ cinq cent mille
visiteurs en juillet pour se loger sur
le site deux possibilités un hôtel de 40
chambres et le camping ce père de
famille a choisi la formule plein air
pratique et économique
on est sur le site ça nous évite les
déplacements la circulation est un peu
difficile on en de la motte jusqu'au
centre fédéral
on est présent il faut composer curé le
matin 7h donc le matin 7 heures on peut
être présent et curieux se lever à 5
heures du matin parce qu'un trafic
routier qui est assez important et plus
économique parce que c'est une semaine
qui revient cher quand même entre la
location d box les engagements tous les
concours pour se préparer donc
c'est un budget sur l'année et c'est le
plus économique bon après il ya des
chambres d'hôtes dans le coin qui sont
aussi très bien mais c'est pas évident
de trouver de la place des chambres
d'hôtes des gîtes c'est l'autre formule
proposée celle ci par les acteurs du
tourisme du loir et cher
de nombreuses familles en profitent
on est logé dans un campement et nos
cheveux sont logés aussi là bas avec
carrière engrange près c'est quoi des
chambres d'hôtes gîtes dans un rayon de
50 kilomètres les hébergements
traditionnels affiche complet l'open lui
se déroule en deux temps et s'achèvera
le 30 juillet